[Música]
[Risas]
i
hola la mía como están
les busco el vídeo se oye les gusta
mucho los clavados
[Música]
cuánto
me gusta mucho los clavados si mucho a
ti también oye como quien quisiera hacer
como al orozco y tú
oye me pueden platicar cuál es su sueño
listas olímpicas seguras a ver más
fuerte que quieren ser
listas olímpica uy qué emoción oye
los juegos olímpicos son la competencia
más grande del mundo deportivo tienen
que ser muy valientes trabajar muy duro
para llegar a esa meta lo prometen van a
ser muy valientes porque tienen muchos
clavados por aprender ok
bueno creo en ustedes y confío en
ustedes ustedes confían en mí
miren bueno van su reto es el siguiente
vamos a dejar esto
su reto vamos a imaginar que estamos en
juegos olímpicos en la final y van a ser
un clavado aquí todos mis amigos que
están allá les van a contar hasta tres y
después los van nos van a calificar ok
ok mía
mía
me ha cueva ejecuta clavado al frente en
posición c
[Aplausos]
ah
la cueva ejecuta clavado atrás en
posición c
[Aplausos]
grabó muy bien lo hicieron muy bien
ahora vamos a ver
vamos a ver van a voltear a la pantalla
y vamos a ver
cuanto nos dan los jueces jueces
califiquen
[Aplausos]
les dieron 10 felicidades de bueno es la
biblia que quieren ser medallistas
olímpicas y es para mí una gran emoción
gracias dígales adiós
[Aplausos]
bueno lo que acaban de ver lo que acaban
de ver es como inicia un sueño a través
de la técnica que yo le llamo técnica de
anclaje
esta técnica de anclaje a través de como
lo vieron con las líneas de crear un
vínculo o un enlace del sueño en este
caso de ir a juegos olímpicos
con una gran experiencia impactante
emocionante qué es lo que hago como
entrenador principalmente cuando son
niños para que ese sueño sea más fuerte
más impactante para buscar ese anhelo
esa ilusión y ese deseo profundo por
conocer y seguir su sueño perdona
bueno esta experiencia pienso que a alía
y mia le durará mucho tiempo le dará un
contenido de vida de retos apasionantes
y de disciplina en busca de su sueño que
llegara a juegos olímpicos
también creo que con esta experiencia
creamos su misión de personal infantil y
para esto yo los invito a ustedes que a
partir de este momento piensen en
ustedes piensen en todas las
conferencias que han visto y la idea que
más les agrade la idea que más les
satisface
vamos a anclar la también y vamos a ver
qué pasa al final
contésteme estas preguntas por favor qué
es lo que más te gusta en la vida el
contenido de tu vida es agradable
valiente divertido
tienes una misión personal los que ya la
tienen felicidades y los que no en mi
caso es una herramienta importante para
el éxito piensa en los roles que
desempeñan en la familia en el trabajo
en la sociedad piensa lo que más te
agrade lo que más te guste lo que más te
apasiona piensa en tus cualidades y
piensa en tus metas a corto y mediano
plazo
ustedes saben hablando de nacimiento de
sueños y ustedes saben de donde nace un
pollito de un huevo verdad miren yo soy
del estado de hidalgo de un de un
pueblito en el cual mi padre era
profesor de primaria y su mejor su mayor
pasatiempo era crear gallos finos de
pelea
y bueno estos animalitos son muy bonitos
muy elegantes pero para mí son muy muy
valientes como los mexicanos como los
clavadistas mexicanos y bueno
cuando era niño mi misión aparte de
estudiar era ir por los huevos me decía
mi padre iván sube por los huevos y ahí
va iban por los huevos que era
recolectar los quitarle el huevo o la
gallina llevarlos con mi padre para que
los marcarán y después de guardarlos
para mí era algo tan importante
para mí era una responsabilidad y me
causaban nervios porque yo sentía que
llevaba entre las manos un tesoro
aquel pollito que podría ser un gallo
campeón
hablando de de pollitos fíjense yo tengo
aquí 12 años ya trabajando como
entrenador y casualmente hace 12 años me
encontré un pollito un pollito muy
especial
tremendo travieso hiperactivo de muy
mala conducta pero con una a una o una
genética y un potencial increíble los
detecte como talento e influir en el en
su mente para guiarlo a los altos
resultados y le digo iván iván el pollo
garcía
oye tienes mucho talento pero no tienes
disciplina ve a todos tus compañeros la
mayoría de ellos son campeones mundiales
juveniles tu actualmente no eres ninguna
figura deportiva pero si haces lo que yo
te digo podrás lograr grandes resultados
hicimos equipo con sus padres de familia
trabajamos de tal manera que el pollo
estaba ocupado de siete de la mañana a
nueve de la noche era nuestra estrategia
para pues para calmarlo porque era
tremendo
muy muy mala mala conducta por cierto
una persona en su formación infantil le
llegó a decir tú vas a ser un criminal
así con esa etiqueta
y vean vean ustedes cuando se detecta el
talento se le hace creer que puede ser
grande y se trabaja con disciplina
valentía y carácter se llega como iván
garcía a medallista olímpico
un día al euros con entrenamiento las
que se da un golpe a la edad de diez
años y veo el analizó
y efectivamente llorando pero con una
inseguridad de ya dejar los clavados y
ya no insistir en su pasión que eran los
clavados y me acerco a ella le digo ale
tienes mucho talento
no desistas tienes que seguir y creo que
tú puedes ser una competidora de nivel
internacional así es de que prepárate
fuerte porque en algún algún momento te
tocará representar a méxico en una
competencia de alto nivel otra ocasión
llega el director del deporte y ustedes
saben que aquí se realizaron los juegos
panamericanos
y me dice iván
sabes qué se va a hacer aquí una alberca
se va a hacer en el parque metropolitano
rápidamente agarre ahí la idea y dije
aquí haré un anclaje con algo porque
porque ella vive muy cerca del parque
metropolitano se fue el director del
deporte ale ven oye qué creés me
preguntaron que si tenía clavadistas
para juegos panamericanos 2012 aquí en
tu ciudad y qué crees que le dije que sí
que tenía una niña que iría a juegos
panamericanos y esa eres tú vale se
quedó con su carita sorprendida
y además sale que crees que le pedí de
favor que te hiciera tu alberca al lado
de tu casa
no vale de veras que entreno a partir de
ese momento hace unas horas
le comenté oye le voy a dar una
conferencia de acuerdo y efectivamente
como un anclaje a esta edad
y pega muy fuerte pues bueno le hicieron
su alberca según ella trabajo muy fuerte
eso es la alberca y que cree no
participo en juegos panamericanos juegos
panamericanos centroamericanos olímpicos
no se participa de 14 años pero lo
importante es que ella estaba preparada
para las altas ligas las altas
competencias porque ya tenía los
clavados de 10 metros y me di a la tarea
de juntar la con paola espinosa
medallista olímpica y trabajamos un año
y que creen que pasó bueno ya lo sabe
se fabricó un sueño y se ganó medalla
olímpica sueño realizado
bueno y dejó huella dejó huella porque
es la medallista olímpica más joven de
la historia de méxico
y bueno les platicaré el siguiente
anclaje con estos guerreros iván garcía
y germán sánchez conocidos en el mundo
como los intrépidos los valientes bueno
en el 2008 los puntos que les digo
ustedes van a ser los mejores del mundo
porque tiene entre el talento tienen el
somatotipo y no es posible que otros les
ganen así que vamos a trabajar lo único
que tienen que hacer y ese la pongo
fácil es que tienen que inventar dos
clavados de astro grado de dificultad y
si ustedes saben ellos tienen los
clavados más difíciles del mundo en
clavados sincronizados sólo tienen que
desearlo quererlo pero de veras
profundamente desearlo trabajamos con
esa filosofía de trascender con una
insistencia de parte del guía que soy yo
como entrenador
todos los días ustedes serán los mejores
del mundo para que no se rindieran
porque los clavados que iban a ser
cuatro y media vueltas adentro y tres
giros al frente nadie del mundo los hace
además les dije
estos clavados serán la estrategia para
que sean los mejores del mundo y también
para ganar medalla olímpica y bueno
trabajamos se realizaron esos esos
clavados pero no me salven mucha gente
del medio me trató de loco decían que
como les lo sometía a esos adolescentes
a esas cargas y cómo iba yo en una
competencia interna
internacional representando a méxico
arriesgar el resultado ellos
pronosticaban que no iba a ganar muchos
me trataron de loco y bueno aquí está el
testimonio
qué
[Música]
recalcaba
necesitamos soñarlo desearlo y trabajar
duro con el corazón de la mano humana
entre la zona
digo así porque las ideas de muchos
otros vivan de ver pintado de
especuladores un ojo es muy realista
porque nos ponía
a preparar clavados pues bueno para
fabricar un sueño por supuesto por
supuesto que se necesita una dosis de
locura
se necesita curiosidad investigación
para tener conocimiento y por supuesto
disciplina y trabajo porque no podemos
tener una atleta sin esos miles de
minutos de trabajo de calidad y vean lo
que se consiguió con este trabajo
a la sociedad
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
se logró la medalla olímpica
con toda esa locura que me caracterizaba
por inventar y poner el nombre en alto a
nuestro país y tendiendo los guerreros
de verdad que en méxico nos consideran
como en el mundo perdón a los mexicanos
nos consideran como unos guerreros y
bueno como ustedes ven yo soy el
encargado de esta fábrica de la escuela
de clavados de jalisco y me considero un
picapedrero porque picado piedra durante
20 años no me he rendido buscando los
talentos inculcándoles esa filosofía de
trascender
y que creen sin ser clavadista nunca me
he tirado en clavado
pero además
le tengo miedo a las alturas si me subo
me subo pero con una atleta ayudarle es
ese es el conecte el enlace que me da el
valor para para vencer mis miedos si
ustedes me preguntan cuál es mi éxito yo
les diría estos elementos tener una
misión personal es muy importante
defender con carácter y valentía tu
sueño trabajar en equipo
pensar positivo y con mis atletas ser
guerrero de minuto a minuto
vivir con contenido con pasión la
búsqueda de tus sueños y trabajar con
disciplina valentía si no arriesgamos no
ganamos en busca de de nuestros retos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]